hey, this is really funny or this is really
weird to use. One of my favorite stories segues
Donald Trump is now reportedly worried that
there's this insurgent movement of leftists
on Fox News that are taking it over and are
going to turn Fox News against Donald Trump.
And there's a really interesting piece in
the daily beast that says that Trump has been
having personal conversations with his friends
to the extent that he has real friends about
how Fox anchors are treating him, quote unfairly.
And he's been asking people, can I really
trust Rupert Murdoch's kids to do what's best
for me? And the gist of this is that Rupert
Murdoch is 88 years old. Uh, his kids are
taking more and more of a role in running
different Murdoch businesses and Trump is
worried that fox is going to turn liberal
and turn against him as a result. And he thinks
he's already seeing that as a result of some
of the Fox News anchors stopping short of
parroting Donald Trump's obvious lies. Trump
is also reportedly telling his senior staff
that he wants them appearing in more places
than just Fox. I guess the idea is if Fox
isn't going to be 100% deferential to them,
he's not going to give them as much access
to his staff. Now, the truth about Rupert
Murdoch's kids is that a Lockland Murdoch
is now the CEO of Fox Corporation. He's a
conservative populist, sort of in the line
of Tucker Carlson.
Rupert Murdoch has another son named James
who's more liberal, but he's not involved
with the network. So the only things that
really happen on air that Trump could be concerned
about are that there is sometimes like really
soft opposition to obvious lies from Trump
or from the people around him. Like sometimes
Shep Smith or Chris Wallace will say, Trump
didn't tell the truth about x or y, or Chris
Wallace will confront a Trump administration
official and say what you just said is not
true. But Trump has been increasingly agitated
by Fox's coverage. Um, recent tweet series
over a weekend or Donald Trump said, quote,
watching Fox News weekend anchors is worse
than watching low ratings, fake news, CNN
or lion, Brian Williams. Remember when he
totally fabricated a war story trying to make
himself into a hero and he got fired. A very
dishonest journalist and the crew of degenerate,
Comcast, NBC, MSNBC, Trump haters who do whatever
Brian and Steve Tell them to do.
Like CNN. NBC is also a way down in the ratings,
but Fox News who failed and getting the very
boring dem debates is now loading up with
Democrats and even using fake unsourced New
York Times as a source of information. Ask
The Times what they paid for the Boston Globe
and what they sold it for. Perron thetical
parentheses lost one point $5 billion or their
old headquarters building disaster or their
unfunded liability. Fox News is changing fast,
but they forgot the people who got there.
So that's almost completely unintelligible.
But let me explain what's going on here because
I've actually explained this before. Fox News
is right-wing, they aren't going to stop being
right wing, but they're not married to Trump.
And you might remember that early in the 2016
Republican primary back in 2015 Fox was not
behind Donald Trump early. And in fact, Fox
News had some very public opposition to Trump
and public spats with Trump. Eventually Trump
kept gaining support.
Fox News came around and Trump's been lucky
enough to have Fox News as the de facto propaganda
arm for his administration for most of the
last two and a half years. But Fox News can
be conservative and bail on Trump and they
may actually do that. And the scariest part
of this is that I predicted that if Trump
breaks with Fox News, he will start promoting
and even crazier channel called Oh, a n or
o a n n the one America News Network. And
he has actually started to push some of their
content out in the last couple of months.
I got a few dozen tweets when Donald Trump
did this two months ago because again, I had
said if Trump bales on fox, he's going to
OAN Trump quoting and responding to a report
from o a n n on Twitter a couple of months
ago and there have been more examples of this
as well and this is like straight up Alex
Jones Breitbart level propaganda.
This may be what Donald Trump turns to if
and when he abandons Fox News, the guy is
on tilt, he's hanging by a thread and an impeachment
inquiry combined with Fox News bailing on
him. If indeed Fox News does could send him
completely out of control in ways we've not
even seen yet. I look forward to being along
for the ride, but at the same time my rational
side recognizes this is really bad for the
United States of America in ways we're going
to address a little bit later on in today's
program. Make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on Instagram at David Pakman show
and follow me on Instagram
as well at David Dot Cacti